erneut macht die zerschlagung eines
kinderschänder netzwerks in deutschland
schlagzeilen und sorgt für
fassungslosigkeit 73 männer sollen in
deutschland weit über ländergrenzen
hinweg unschuldige kinder missbraucht
haben die taten gefilmt haben und
miteinander geteilt haben
hauptverdächtiger an der spitze des
grausamen netzwerks ein ehemann it
ingenieur markus r
das was ich gesehen habe hat mich bis
ins mark erschüttert
ein solches ausmaß an
menschenverachtender brutalität
und gefühlloser gleichgültigkeit
gegenüber dem leid von kleinen kindern
den schmerzen und ihren schreien und
ihrer offensichtlichen angst ist mir
noch nicht begegnet und so etwas habe
ich mir auch nicht vorstellen können
wermelskirchen in nordrhein westfalen
ein kleiner ort der das zuhause für
viele junge familien mit kleinen kindern
ist insgesamt leben hier rund 600
einwohnern und einer von ihnen das
missbrauchs minister markus rindt in
wermelskirchen im rheinisch bergischen
kreis in nordrhein-westfalen lebte
markus er zirka ein halbes jahr bevor er
am dritten dezember 2021 von
spezialkräften in seinem haus
festgenommen wurde er ist verheiratet
ist 44 jahre alt und arbeitet als
computerspezialist zu seinen nachbarn
hat er noch nicht so viel kontakt gehabt
die nachbarn beschreiben ihn als
freundlich man grüßte sich auf der
straße aber gut gekannt haben sie nicht
dazu hat er offenbar nicht lange genug
hier gewohnt
markus r sein leben seine person klingt
so unscheinbar doch umso grausamer seine
taten zwölf kinder soll die bestie
missbraucht haben die hälfte seiner
opfer soll nicht älter als drei jahre
sein das jüngste gerade einmal einen
monat alt
zugang zu seinen opfern verschafft sich
der 44-jährige in dem er seine dienste
als babysitter anbietet über ebay
kleinanzeigen schaltet markus r anzeigen
seine opfer missbrauchte er dann in den
häusern der familien teilweise soll er
seinem kleinen opfern vorher
betäubungsmittel gegeben haben
doch als wären diese bestialischen taten
nicht genug die ermittler finden bei dem
verheirateten mann und arbeitnehmer
232 datenträger 30 terabyte
videomaterial seiner grausamen taten und
aufnahmen anderer kinderschänder
so decken die ermittler einen pädophilen
netzwerk auf das ganz deutschland erneut
erschüttert den kinderschänder markus r
kommen die ermittler durch ein verfahren
hunderte kilometer von wermelskirchen
entfernt auf die spur
endete mit einem angeklagten pädophilen
in berlin und teilte mit diesen
tatverdächtigen fotos und videos nach
markus erst festnahme sichten die
ermittler 17 tage lang das
sichergestellte material und enttarnen
so mindestens 73 weitere kinderschänder
verteilt durch die ganze bundesrepublik
die über jahre hinweg millionen an
videos und fotos miteinander teilten
insgesamt ermittelt die polizei in 14
bundesländern eine spur geht sogar bis
nach österreich haupttäter in diesen
kinderschänderring markus r
sind diese videos sehr lang teilweise
dauern sie über 30 jahre sogar 40
minuten
entsprechend lang ist das leiden der
kinder doch markus erst bestialisches
netzwerk erstreckt sich noch weiter bis
zum münsteraner missbrauchs komplex den
eher mitleid 2020 springen mehr als 50
männer missbrauchte und vergewaltigte
unschuldige kleine kinder über jahre
hinweg in einer gartenlaube in münster
und anderen orten in deutschland an der
spitze des münsteraner missbrauchs
komplexes adrian v bereits verurteilt zu
14 jahren haft
unfassbar markus r und adrian pfahl
standen jahre lang miteinander in
kontakt mit kontakt meine ich
dass der täter aus wermelskirchen war
ein missbrauch des täters aus münster
zugesehen und offenbar anweisung zu
missbrauchshandlungen gegeben hat wie
viel leid wie viel schmerz diese bestien
über unschuldige kleine kinder brachten
es ist nicht vorstellbar wieso die
ermittler markus er erst zwei jahre nach
der sprengung des münster missbrauchs
komplexes entdeckten unklar markus r
sitzt seit dem dritten dezember in
untersuchungshaft
deutschlandweit ermitteln die behörden
unter hochdruck um die bestialischen
kinderschänder zu stoppen wer dafür
sorgen wir kriegen euch
vielleicht nicht heute aber eines tages
stehen wir für eure türen
ja es ist nicht vorstellbar es gibt
experten die müssen sich auch mit dem
nicht vorstellbaren auseinandersetzen
christian marsdorf ist so einer
professor für kriminalistik von der
hochschule für wirtschaft und recht in
berlin und erst jetzt hier bei mir im
studio
hast du auf ein ehemann ein normaler
angestellter
heimlich samir der seit jahren pornos
missbraucht kinder brutal filmt das
kommt an die spitze eines riesigen
pädophilenrings was muss das für ein
mensch sein
dann zunächst muss man sagen dieses
unauffällige was wir hier
sendung gehört haben das unauffällige
verhalten dieses eigene gliedert sein
und ein ganz normales leben
anführungsstrichen dass es keine
ausnahme das ist ein kennzeichen dieser
täter die sehr gut und dann bürgerlich
deckmantel leben und agieren können
gerade das ist ja die tarnung die sie
brauchen um dann eben ihre schrecklichen
taten verüben zu können was die
persönlichkeit das tier das angeht wir
können glaube ich wäre nicht so weit
denken um die persönlichkeit für uns zu
skizzieren das ist fernab jeder
vorstellung insbesondere man sich die
daten anschaut über die wir hier
sprechen
aber wir können mit sicherheit sagen
dass es ein mensch ist der sich
vollkommen außerhalb allem was
vorstellbar was norman angeht regeln
angeht was moral und ethik angestellt
hat und seine taten so verübt hat dass
eine möglichst große anzahl von
beteiligten ebenfalls davon profitieren
können das ist alleine schon ein ganz
besonders kennzeichen ich habe gesagt
das unscheinbare ist das kennzeichen
gibt es trotzdem irgendwelche ich sage
mal früh waren anzeichen die man dann
erkennen kann der mann war verheiratet
beispielsweise kann eine frau
so etwas mitbekommen irgendwann gibt es
irgendwelche anzeichen wo man aufmerksam
werden könnte also habe oft genug mit
männern gearbeitet vernehmung die
sexuellen missbrauch von kindern
begangen haben ich habe nie ein system
erkennen können oder indikatoren
erkennen können die darauf hinweisen
dass diese menschen und menschen sind
die solche taten fähig sind solche taten
zu begehen teilweise haben wir mit
sympathischen teilweise mit eloquenten
menschen zu tun treiber sind einfach nur
unauffälligen menschen es gibt
eigentlich kein allgemeingültiges
frühwarnsystem das hängt auch damit
zusammen dass der sexuelle missbrauch
von kindern ubiquitären gesellschaft ist
also über in allen schichten und allen
orten möglichkeiten das ist also nicht
etwas was wir einen bestimmten bereich
zuordnen können dann ganz fokussiert
darauf schauen können deshalb ja auch
die möglichkeit das so lange zu tun die
ersten videoaufnahmen stammen offenbar
aus dem jahr
1993 bereits ja also zum einen die frage
wie kann das sein dass das so lange
unentdeckt bleibt und zum anderen aber
auch die frage wie kommt es dass jetzt
plötzlich in letzter zeit immer mehr
aufgedeckt wird
293 war eine zeit wo technische
möglichkeiten noch ganz anders gestaltet
werden als heute das heißt also die
technischen möglichkeiten der täter und
täterinnen aber auch die technischen
möglichkeiten der ermittlungsbehörden
insofern ist das eine andere zeit und es
war sehr gut möglich dann zu dieser zeit
auch eben recht verdeckt zu bleiben der
zweite teil ist diese gruppen diese
netzwerke aber leider auch die
einzeltäter arbeiten ja sehr konspirativ
also das ist ja ein großer teil ihres
tat ihres tatbegehungs muss dass der
phänomenologie dass sie es schaffen die
dinge von der öffentlichkeit
fernzuhalten und das müssen sie auch tun
denn sie wissen dass diese taten
gerichtet sind und daß aufmerksamkeit
mittlerweile scharf genug ist auch auf
anfangsverdacht dieser tat zu reagieren
das ist etwas was wir mit
berücksichtigen müssen heute dieser
situation die wir jetzt schildern hängt
das sicherlich damit zusammen dass
missbrauch komplexe großen umfangs
aktenkundig geworden sind offensichtlich
geworden sind und dass man aus den
ermittlungen heraus immer noch neue
ermittlungsansätze generieren kann und
da muss die polizei da müssen
ermittlungsbehörden dran bleiben und
müssen sehen dass nicht noch weiteres
leid geschieht und dass wir keine
zeitlichen verzögerung um diese dinge
aufzuklären wir kriegen wir euch alle
hat der nordrhein westfälische
innenminister herbert reul sagt vielen
dank es dort